No,
I've been describing the relationship,
the intimate relationship between sex and violence than the chimpanzee social
system.
This lecture and forever after we can shift our focus to humans and we ought to
ask what's stayed pretty much the same and what has changed.
And today I'm going to discuss two topics,
uh,
one war in humans,
which hasn't changed all that much or even certainly see a continuity.
And then I'm going to talk about,
uh,
fecundity in,
in humans,
how many children we bear compared to chimpanzees.
And you'll see there's a very big difference there.
So,
uh,
the most obvious similarity and the one that gets the public quite excited is
this similarity in,
oops,
that was wrong.
Come on.
Oh,
there we go.
Come on.
Okay.
So a violent death has always been very important aspect for humans,
especially,
well all the time.
But I'm going to talk now about what's called primitive times.
And this is data from a tribe that's in Paraguay,
in South America in the period just before it had real contact with Western,
uh,
people.
So it has nothing to do with,
with,
with maternity.
This is apparently the way they lived for time in memorial.
And what this table does is list the number of deaths by age,
getting,
putting them in different age groups.
And here's just children,
or we would call them infants almost zero to three years.
And you can notice this at Navigant,
amount of death.
This is all illnesses,
that's communicable diseases and all kinds of other diseases.
That's the percentage of deaths from that.
And then there's other causes,
a congenital degenerative accidents and some,
but here's violence.
Various forms of violence.
56% of infants from zero to three died because of violence.
Here is children age four to 14
and
again,
we see that all illnesses about percent accidents,
violence,
74% violence.
Now adults during this as a 45 year period,
the,
the number,
the number of years in the periods are not equal.
And here his illness,
28% not insignificant accident,
not insignificant,
but the various forms of violent deaths,
46% and it's only when you get over 60 years of age.
So in each of those three age categories,
violent deaths have been the dominant form of death.
It's separated by males and females,
males,
females total.
And that's true for males and for females.
The song I'm showing you,
this sum totals,
it's only even after age 60,
violent death is still the dominant cause,
the third of deaths,
but it's the only age at which it doesn't really be 50 approximate,
at least half the deaths only when you get that old.
So it's,
it's quite striking.
Uh,
how significant a violent death is.
Inhuman demography and several things should be noticed there.
Uh,
that communicable diseases are less important for hunter gatherers.
These were very primitive hunter gatherers.
The RJ and one of your readings is,
is from their own description of,
of the way they live in the dangers that they face,
um,
that communicable diseases are less important because the population density is
so low later we'll see.
And so diseases just don't get to pass around.
We'll see later that the influence of disease rises drastically,
especially among infants when the population density gets high enough so that
people pass around diseases quite common.
Another thing.
You may notice from this that more individuals die in the first three years of
infancy,
131 deaths than in the 45 years of adulthood,
126 deaths.
So deaths in infancy are 50 per year or 15 times as common as deaths,
uh,
in a,
in adulthood and have 383 people who are catalog year.
Only seven people died of old age.
All of them had other really identifiable causes.
So,
uh,
given this background of the significance of violence,
and this includes more than just war,
uh,
but does not include deaths from animals being eaten by animals,
which is an ax considered an accident.
So,
um,
uh,
defining war talk going back to is we talked a lot about chimp,
what you might call chimp war and now talk about human wars.
Let's take a definition of war as the intentional killing of members of one
group by members of another group.
And the killing is done because they are members of a group,
not because of any prior or a particular individ conflict between individuals.
It's a group thing that determines the two sites that they're going to kill each
other.
So the human social system in primitive times and uh,
in some politically correct circuit,
not supposed to,
you were use the word primitive,
but I,
I use it in its original sense of living closer to the way humans did millions,
thousands,
many thousands or millions of years ago.
It's an early,
an early form of,
of being human.
So during that time we lived in small tribal groups and they're molting male
groups.
Again,
we talked about most animals,
solitary males with strong male bonding,
competition for status,
lots of intergroup conflict,
competition for females and violence against females.
Everything that we know says that humans have,
have lived in that,
uh,
in communities with those characteristics since as far back as as we can,
as we know.
And that is the same description you would put on chimpanzees.
Uh,
the archeological data shows that through early farming times we lived in these
small dispersed settlements and the average size seems to be in the same range
as current chimpanzees about 40 individuals size and communities range.
But when you dig up these,
the archeologists dig up these old settlements there,
that ballpark.
Uh,
the anthropologists studying currently alive,
people again find that the smallest organized group of humans is a politically
autonomous group consisting of 20 to 50 individuals with the headman head man.
And they called this the proper anthropological term is a band.
And again,
basically the same size as a chimp community
among chimpanzees as I've described to intergroup violence as a hit and run a
affair,
uh,
with small groups of groups of chimps from one community patrol their boundary.
They detect a,
an isolated individual,
a very small group or even better,
a single individual and other community.
And then they attack in,
in,
uh,
anthropologists tell us that primitive warfare has exactly the same,
characteristics,
uh,
among current primitive groups.
Uh,
the communist form of combat is called raids and,
and bushes and communities are constantly engaging in this hit and run.
These hit and run raids on each other and they spring ambushes to,
uh,
to catch loan members of the other group.
Uh,
I live for a while among headhunters in Borneo.
Presumably they weren't headhunters anymore at that time and it was perfectly
acceptable for them to go out and find a child from a neighboring community.
Same,
same tribe,
same everything,
but the neighboring community playing by the river,
catch him and take off his skull.
And they had their addicts were,
were decorated with skulls.
None of this was big.
You know,
that whole community fighting that whole community.
But little raids,
finding individuals didn't matter.
Child,
adult,
uh,
nothing,
mattered like that.
So,
uh,
so you can draw many similarities between,
to chimp organization of,
of these,
this lethal rating.
And if human warfare.
And so how does one think about this?
Well,
there are two possibilities.
Either whatever you think of the chimp warfare and the causes of it,
you have to think that a lot of that is still causing human warfare.
Or you can say as many,
uh,
utopians do that they're different,
that no human,
human warfare has nothing to do with chimp warfare.
One of the ways to prove or disprove that,
uh,
would be to look in history as far as we can tell.
And if it has different causes,
what you have to assume as we know for sure that this is what chimps do.
We presume that their ancestors,
so millions of years ago before we split did that,
but we don't really know that.
Uh,
but we presume it's true that chimps did,
did that.
And then some time in human history we have to find a period where we stopped
doing it.
And then at a later period we started doing it again.
But now for totally different set of reasons than for the chimp reasons.
So the strategy of trying to figure out this question is then to go back in
history and gathered the archeological,
anthropological,
whatever data we can gather and try to find out,
has there been a period in human history where we were not,
uh,
did not have this intercommunal violence.
And the people who believe that war has different causes,
uh,
is,
they think agriculture started because land becomes valuable or private property
of some sort.
People wanted to get each of those private property or governments,
modern state governments,
or very commonly you'll hear that it has something to do with maternity.
That civilization has somehow corrupted the pure nature of early humans who were
a wonderful human beings and didn't go to war.
So what was the situation for prehistoric humans?
So we can go back to the neanderthals which are close to as kind of sisters
subspecies.
And these guys as you know,
heavy musculature,
robust bones,
they were strong,
obviously strong characters.
But when you take your study there,
graveyards,
40% of neanderthal skeletons have head injuries and that.
How does one attribute that either they were very clumsy and accident prone and
always somehow managed to fall on their head?
As far as we know,
they didn't climb trees very much and hang upside down and fall.
Uh,
or there was a lot of club wielding and head bashing going on.
Homo Sapiens,
not,
not neanderthals.
The earliest human burials that haven't just decayed away are about 20,000 to
35,000 years ago.
And when you dig them up,
what do you find?
Spear points embedded in the bones.
Cranio fractures,
scalping marks and so forth.
These burial grounds are found wherever archeologists look a,
some of the most prominent ones are Italy,
France,
Egypt,
Czechoslovakia,
that because that's where archeologists have had access to dig,
had a 13,000 year old cemetery in Sudan.
Over 40% of the skeletons had spear or Arrow points embedded in them.
The wounds,
there were children buried there.
The wounds found from the children that's in the cemetery.
We're all execution shots in the head or the neck.
They're just bashed to death in the head of the neck.
This was not like one burial from one horrific incident.
It was color used over several generations.
It was a continuing cemetery.
And many of the adults show not only the wounds that caused their death,
but many prior,
uh,
wounds,
bone cracks and skull cracks that had healed.
So you can see both a wound from some prior conflict which had healed and the
new wound,
which caused the death at this moment.
And individuals had gotten into a lot of conflict.
One skeleton had 20 different wounds,
that means bone cracks that you could still see a 13,000 years later.
And soft tissue,
soft tissue injury,
we just don't have any way of knowing about
when you get to modern times are still prehistoric mean before we have any
written records,
uh,
before anything you'd call civilization,
things get a little stylized that,
that clearly culture is advancing.
There's a middle stone age cave in Germany,
only five or 10,000,
five to 10,000 years old where there are two caches of skulls,
just the skulls are there.
They're neatly arranged like eggs in a basket and they are then disembodied
heads of men and women and children with multiple heads,
multiple holes knocked by axis into their skulls.
And uh,
I don't have,
you didn't show a picture of that,
but this is a modern version of this actually from Thailand.
This is the way skulls can get,
uh,
arranged this,
this,
that picture has a totally different kind of purpose.
Um,
you,
how many of you remember ice man,
the guy that got unfrozen from the Alps,
you're all aware,
aware of this?
So in 1991,
uh,
one of the glaciers in the Alps disgorge the stone age man who died,
they think 5,300 years ago,
and as at least a good number of,
you know,
he had a lot of press and he was called the iceman,
uh,
ends.
And since it took 5,300 years for him to come down the mountain,
he must've died pretty high up,
uh,
in,
in some high point to the past in the mountain.
So it was just assumed that he died,
uh,
froze to death while trying to cross the Alps and a gun case in the ice.
And 55,000 years later came down,
so for 10 years,
academic opinion said that.
And then they finally got it,
got around to,
uh,
taking a cat scan of the body,
and guess what?
They found a two centimeter Flint.
Arrowhead had ripped through his scapula and,
uh,
lodged six centimeters deep into his shoulder.
He had been shot from behind by an Arrow and he died of internal bleeding.
Again,
a violent death.
You come to even more recent times,
a native American settlement,
American Indians,
uh,
for about 13,
25 Aidy.
So almost 200 years before their contact to have any contact with,
with Westerners.
And this contains the remains of 500 men,
women and children.
And this is kind of not a great picture,
but again,
uh,
what,
what you see that these victims had been scalped mutilated.
And then something a little unique left exposed for a few months to scavengers
before,
uh,
being buried again as a form of punishment,
disrespect or whatever for the victim.
You're not only slaughter than mutilate them,
maybe mutilate and then slaughter them,
and then you leave the scavengers to,
to chew on them.
And then finally they get buried
in short archeology,
documents,
warfare,
and every well studied region for the past 10,000 years,
which is when we have very good records.
Okay?
So that's what you can dig up.
The other thing is to look,
uh,
at,
currently primitive human beings.
And they ask how many of them are truly a peaceful?
And so the anthropologists now take over from the archeologists what the
anthropologists funds that 90 to 95% of known societies have been involved in
war,
that we can document of one sample of 50 societies,
45 engaged in war,
frequently for did not engage in war because they had recently been driven into
isolated refuges,
uh,
by warfare.
And if any of you been to the Indians and Mara Indians in Lake Titicaca in Peru,
it's a big tourist spot.
There's an island in the middle of Lake Titicaca and they're very peaceful
people.
They live on reads,
they don't have anybody to fight.
They were pushed off the mainland by war and they've just been isolated.
So that's one of the group that said,
well,
we haven't seen them get into any wars,
but they have no possibility,
uh,
of it.
Uh,
and one which is called peaceful in the monarchy,
which live actually in the Sierra Nevada mountains of California.
They say we'll calm,
peaceful because they only rarely go to war.
Another study,
66% of primitive societies who went to war every year,
75% at least every two years,
and up to 90% went to war at least once every five years.
So the evidence is mounting up that,
uh,
so called primitive humans are not a terribly peaceful lot.
The Donnie tribes in of New Guinea had seven full battles and nine raids in one,
five and a half month period.
We can tell some anthropologists for sitting there for five and a half months.
And that's,
that's the number that he counted.
One Yanomamo village that's,
uh,
in Venezuela it was rated 25 times in 15 months.
In the u s west,
80,
86% of the Indian tribes went rating or had to resist rates at least once a
year.
Now you come to groups that are usually peaceful.
So there's a group in Malaysia called the semi,
and they were recruited.
So,
but during World War Two,
as you know,
the Japanese took Malaysia and the British incited a sort of a guerrilla
movement against the Japanese.
So they retained a scouts by the British,
uh,
to fight.
And I'm sorry,
this was later.
This was,
there were scouts to fight the grill and grill insurgency by coming by I suppose
to communists,
but eventually some of the guerrillas killed a few of the semi,
a few of their kinsmen.
And then even though they had never been known to be war,
like they became extremely war.
Like when say semi veteran recalled,
we killed,
killed,
killed the melees would rob the corpses,
but we did not want anything.
We thought only of killing.
Why truly we were drunk with blood.
Sounds like that.
There are cultural,
like many cultures have repressed the killing for some instinct or killing
propensity for for one reason or another.
And then when the cultural controls came off,
boom,
the,
the instinct just roars up totally full blown almost instantaneously.
And we've seen that in so many cases that Yugoslavia recently where people live
together for a very long time in moderate harmony.
Uh,
all of a sudden,
Bang,
they start killing each other.
Uh,
the Germans in the 19 before the depression in the 1920s were among the most
civilized people on earth and science and education.
Boom.
They become savages almost immediately.
So I think the indication is there is something inside of us ready to pop out.
Culture can repress it,
but demagogues know how to stick their finger into populations and pull out that
us them and vilify the them and bring us right back to chimpanzee days.
Uh,
you all know,
yeah,
it was the center for study of the Cambodian genocide where now one group of
people,
the Cambodians sort of split into two and the slaughter,
it was terrible.
How have you seen,
how many of you seen the movie,
the killing fields?
How many of you know about the Cambodian genocide?
Again,
most of you,
but not,
not all of you.
It's one of the most recent,
most terrific,
uh,
kinds of killing
and the,
this killing is,
can be,
what basically happens is that one group does not consider another group.
Humans.
And if you look in primitive languages,
very often the word for human is the same as the word for their group,
whatever their group is.
And in the American Indians,
that was also,
uh,
a common,
kind of phenomenon.
There's a good report from March 18th,
1690,
uh,
in salmon falls,
New Hampshire were a girl named mercy short lived.
They were rated by the Abenaki Indians that was at that time,
69.
Of course,
a real frontier town.
Mercy saw them kill her parents and three of her brothers and sisters,
she was taken to on a long winter march to Canada.
The captors sort of dragged her up to Canada.
During that March,
he saw a five year old boy chopped to bits,
a young girl's scalped and was forced to watch with her hands tied as another
fellow.
Captive was stripped bound to a stake and tortured with fire after which the op
and Aki danced about him and it every term turn they did with their knives,
cut ups of his flesh from his naked limbs and throw them with his blood into his
face.
Remember,
there's someone who's already a captive with the hands tied,
so there's no immediate threat.
It's a,
it's a clear sign of just not considering these outgroup individuals as humans
that all group chimpanzees have once one set of morals Torta in,
in,
in group.
And as a,
as I've told you that in the wild,
the male male conflicts never result in death nor did the male female conflicts
within a group.
Uh,
but in an outgroup if possible,
they always result in death.
Now what is,
when one think of that,
of this,
there's a very interesting story,
uh,
from early America is actually a miracle vis Bucci after whom America is named.
And you know,
Columbus discovered America 1492,
10 years later,
uh,
they were exploring all around and Vespucci went on,
one of the exploration expeditions along the coast to South America and he had
some interaction with the local tribes people and had some interpreters on
board.
Columbus had brought some natives back to Europe and they were able to do some
kind of translation and he was very interested that how different they were from
Europeans.
Their marriages are not with one woman,
but with as many as they like and without much ceremony.
Meaning they just get married very casually.
And we have known someone who had 10 women married to him.
They were very prolific people,
meaning having lots of children,
but they have no heirs because they hold no property.
Even childbirth is without pain.
Coke women in parturition do not use any ceremony as ours do the everything go
on the same day to the fields and wash themselves.
It seems that they hardly feel their parturition,
parturition giving,
giving birth.
Now you can see that what he's dealing with is the 15 hundreds there were in the
late renaissance attitude,
political science theory.
What is it that causes wars between societies,
which it had lots of back then.
And one of the issues is original sin.
These are very religious people.
And uh,
what was the,
the major punishment for Eve's eating of the apple.
Okay.
Pain in childbirth,
severe pain in childbirth.
Here were some people that had no pain in childbirth and he,
he waxes poetic about that,
where they absolved of original sin.
Uh,
that's the kind of issue that,
that's an in his mind.
He also says they are people who lived in many years and according to their
succession,
we have known many men who have four generations living.
So that's about 80 is what is he referring to here again from the Bible,
this,
the span of life.
What's the span of life?
70 years.
Very hard to fit four generations into that.
So again,
he's reflecting that this,
these are not people,
uh,
like European people.
So he goes on with all the wonders of their civilization or there and
civilization,
whatever you want to call it.
But he says quote,
they are a warlike people.
And when they fight,
they do so very cruelly.
And that side,
which is Lord of the battlefield,
bury their own dead,
but the enemy dead,
they cut up and eat.
One of their men confessed to me that he had eaten the flesh of more than 200
bodies
continuing for speechy talking.
The most astonishing thing about their wars and cruelty is that we could find no
reason for them since they have no property or lords or kings or desire for
plunder or lust to rule,
which seems to me to be the causes of war and disorder.
Again,
straight,
late renaissance theory,
political science theory.
When we ask them to tell us the cause of the war and disorder,
they could give no other reason except that this war began among them a long
time ago and they wished to avenge the death of their ancestors.
So it's,
it's a,
it's a very interesting passage.
Um,
the Indians,
you know,
Vespucci is ideas that original sin is what causes this.
And then political,
the,
the sins that humans do have,
the lust for power,
et Cetera,
is what causes all these wars.
And none of that fits,
uh,
these South American Indians.
Uh,
the same message that the color,
it's not obvious what the cause of these wars is,
comes from modern anthropology.
So,
you know,
the Yanomamo of Venezuela and Brazil who are very violent people there,
there was a book called the fierce fierce people that describes them.
They're very,
very warlike there in that border between Venezuela and Brazil,
they're involved in almost constant warfare.
And yet,
what are they after?
Yanomamo villages,
a Shriner by abundant unoccupied territory.
They're just not settlement to settlement to settlement.
There's,
there's plenty of space in which they could expand.
Napoleon Shania on you may have heard of the anthropologist who studies the
animal believes that the fighting between them was department apparently
motivated only by desires to exact revenge and capture.
Women
seem to come across this before,
but again,
just as an within,
as in chimpanzees,
in primitive warfare,
females are killed as often as they are captured.
Uh,
and most of these primitive tribes as well as modern peoples have difficulty,
uh,
getting food not as a cause of war,
but as a result of war,
things get so disrupted by war that that's the reason they have trouble getting
food.
Okay.
All of this is archaeological and anthropological studying times or peoples who
don't have really any writing system.
So in a sense it's pre historic.
Once we come to writing the record,
the record of violence
slows hot and heavy.
Uh,
the first account of the exploits of mortals are our military histories.
The earliest writing of the Chinese,
the Greeks and the Romans are concerned with wars and warrior kings the most.
My,
my in hieroglyphic texts are devoted to the genealogies,
biographies,
and military exploits of the Mayan kings.
The earliest Egyptian hieroglyphics record the victories of Egypt.
First Pharaohs,
uh,
the first,
secular literature written in cuneiform recounts the adventures of the Warrior
King Gilgamesh.
The early and extreme more lightness of the earliest civilizations is laid out
in the Bible.
You're just read the Bible and you get the whole message I'm giving you.
Uh,
the earliest written part of the Old Testament exodus recounts the brutal Hebrew
conquest of Canaan.
So numbers,
uh,
31,
seven,
18,
uh,
the Israelites get the 10 commandments,
thou shalt not kill,
and then they go off to conquer Canaan with,
with lots and lots,
lots of killing.
They wage war against the Midianites as the Lord.
This is one of my favorite passages.
Uh,
they wage war against the Midianites that the Lord had commanded Moses and
killed every male among them.
But the Israelites kept the women of the Midianites with their children as
captives.
When Moses learned about this,
the captains came back thump their chest.
We've had a great victory.
We've killed all the men.
And here we have the women and children as captives.
Moses becomes angry.
So you have spared all the women why?
They are the very ones who prompted the unfaithfulness of the Israelites toward
the Lord slay.
Therefore,
every male child in every woman who has had intercourse with a man,
but you may spare and keep for yourselves.
All girls who have had no intercourse with a man,
an echo of the chimpanzees,
who when a female tries to transfer,
if she has children,
she's a goner.
If she's young,
presumably a virgin,
then she will probably be allowed to transfer.
After the fall of Jericho,
the Israelites quote put to the sword all living creatures of the city,
men,
women,
young and old,
as well as oxen,
sheep and asses.
Next,
they attacked.
Uh,
I,
there fell that day,
a total of 12,000 men and women,
the entire population of I.
Okay,
so the,
the clear thing,
it's quite striking how this come.
So soon after the 10 commandments that was clearly going on is just as engine.
There's an Ingroup and clearly the 10 commandments has made intended for the
ingroup.
Thou shalt not kill straight chimpanzee.
However,
outgroups
if you don't kill them all,
you're,
you're not obeying God's commandments.
So in very modern times,
uh,
atrocities continue with no lessening of,
of the,
of the horrific nature of it compare to chimps,
early human beings.
And they'll describe one of one famous event to which,
how many of you know about the rape of Nanking?
Again,
not all of you,
all of you should know these things that I referred to are very important
things.
Uh,
this is during World War II in I think it was 1937,
the Japanese were trying to conquer China and there's a big place and they were
getting rid of the frustrated cause.
They're in Japan is a small place in China,
a huge place and it's not an easy thing to do,
but they captured a city called,
uh,
nine king and the south of the Yangtze River.
In short order.
The Japanese Cloeter 350,000 people,
the total population of nine king at the time,
it was only about 650,000 and several hundred thousand had already fled.
In short,
they basically killed every Chinese that they can find just like the Bible
stories or the chimpanzee stories.
A Japanese newspaper reporter watch Chinese prisoners being bayoneted on the top
of the city wall.
One by one.
The prisoners fell down into the,
to the outside of the wall.
Blood spattered everywhere.
The chilling atmosphere made one's hair stand on end and limbs tremble with
fear.
So this report is talking only from Japanese and we'll see not Nazi sources
because the possibility the Chinese sources may be exaggerating or something,
but the belief is that neither the Japanese,
no,
the Nazi sources would exaggerate.
Another Japanese military correspondent,
even more constraint described another locale where the murders were by Samurais
style decapitations those in the second row,
we're forced to dump the separate bodies into the river before they themselves
were beheaded.
The killing went on nonstop from morning until night,
but they were only able to kill 2000 persons that way.
The next day,
tired of killing in this fashion,
they set up machine guns so great.
Was the slaughter that the Japanese general complained that he could not find
ditches deep enough to bury the enormous pile of corpses.
Tens of thousands of Chinese women were raped often in schools and nunneries
thousands more were put into sexual slavery,
forced into prostitution.
Who knew referred to in Japanese as public toilets.
The women forced into prostitution's.
Many soldiers went beyond rape to disembowel women slice off their breasts,
nailed them alive to walls.
Fathers were forced to rape their daughters and sons.
Their mothers not only did live burials,
castration and the carving of Oregon's and roasting of people become routine,
but more diabolical torches were practice like hanging people from their tongues
on iron hooks are burying people to their waists and watch them being a tour and
watched them being torn apart by German shepherds.
So sickening was the spectacle that even the Nazis in the city were horrified
when the Japanese took Singapore.
Right after Pearl Harbor,
they shot and decapitated another 20,000,
uh,
Chinese.
So that was just a,
a modern example to show you that whatever this is in humans that makes us
wanting to kill members of another group,
it is totally unfettered by anything that you might call a control or,
or a civilization when it breaks out.
The violence is just incredible.
So the bottom line is that war seems to be characteristic of almost all
[inaudible] and possibly all human societies at all times in our history.
There is no example,
no,
no period,
which we can find out where there's a discontinuity between the chimpanzee
behavior and our current behavior.
And so again,
I think whatever
you think of what's causing the chimpanzee more,
you're probably have to consider very much the same explanation for,
for human war,
the amount of death.
I showed you one example from one tribe,
the achene South American,
any one tribe,
uh,
good experience may or may not be characteristic.
This is from a book,
uh,
Lawrence Keely,
a war before civilization,
which traces a lot of the information I've been giving you.
And what he does is he,
he collects all the data than anybody has ever captured,
not just that,
that are sort of,
he can get some idea of the percentages of deaths by war.
And this is percent of deaths from warfare.
This is males.
Uh,
and this is everybody together.
So in these are different tribes at different times for whom we have data.
And you'll see that the numbers,
the mail numbers go up to 50 or 60% of male deaths are from these wars and the
deaths of everybody,
which is,
which is this is somewhat smaller,
uh,
a fifth or a sixth,
15 to 20% of deaths,
but going up of course to two,
uh,
40% of deaths.
So what the point he's trying to make with this graph is,
here's primitive warfare.
These are darkly colored bands.
What he calls primitive warfare.
And the white bands,
uh,
are uh,
so called civilizations and he called civilization.
Anything that has a state like the Aztecs had a state.
And one of these is as techs and from the data that one has,
we are,
even though we think of World War II and all of these current incredible wars
and all our technology devoted towards what's happening is that we have much
more,
many,
many more people die than did in the past.
But the population of humans has grown so much that the percentage is not so
huge and our wars are less frequent rather than having raids almost
continuously,
as in a lot of primitive warfare.
We have wars every 15 or 20 years or so.
And J in general between any,
any two groups fighting each other.
So what he shows again from the data that one has,
which has large and unknown error bars,
the civilized warfare,
which is the Aztecs,
uh,
France in the 19th century with the Napoleonic wars and the 1870 war,
western Europe in the 17th century.
Lots and lots of wars in the 16 hundreds,
uh,
US and Europe and the 20th century will go one world war two and so forth.
That as far as he can tell,
the fraction of,
of all deaths that is caused by war is decreasing.
And one possible,
very nice way of looking at human history is that humans have some sort of a
propensity called an instinct.
If you like to identify an Ingroup and everyone else's outgroups these in groups
can be nationality,
they can be religion,
they can be color of skin,
they can be language.
Language is a big source of conflict in Canada and Belgium,
all kinds of places.
Uh,
almost anything we'll,
we'll do it can be Yale versus Harvard or Berkeley College versus Calhoun
College.
Uh,
and you know,
red sox,
you know,
Pete with a red sox fan,
the English who were generally very civilized get into a soccer stadium and they
start killing each other.
So humans have this enormous desire to identify ingroup and outgroup and you
know,
we even now pay,
you know,
you to advertise the company cause anything that looks like a group membership
symbol.
Humans love that and we'll pay a lot to have no hat or a,
uh,
a name of,
of some team or even some company on them.
And we have very different morals toward the ingroup and the outgroup.
And uh,
it seems that that's what still still going on,
uh,
to us that as Tom,
we have that still.
But as time goes on,
because of increased communication and increased education,
probably the,
what we consider the ingroup grows.
First it was your little village of,
you know,
little hamlet of 40 people.
Then maybe you organize it into some sort of a tribe of a thousand people and
gradually grows you.
If you read the history of Europe,
they're all these little cities,
say Greece would city states a whole city could consider one family with a lot
of divisions within it.
A renaissance,
Italy,
you have the metta cheese in the potsy killing each other,
families within cities,
but gradually grows.
You get nation states and as they grow,
the wars get less because people within say,
France don't generally have wars with each other,
but France will have a huge war with Germany.
So the group that people consider us gets larger,
the frequency of war goes down,
but since you have so many people fighting,
so many people,
the war causes more and more deaths and possibly this is optimistic that as we
become more interconnected and we'd consider more people,
us and fewer people them,
that gradually this behavior will disappear.
But that's just guesswork.
Okay.
Um,
now Keely who gathered a lot of this data,
he has his own summary and again in frustration about not really understanding
other than what these wars are all about.
He does not accept any idea that there's any biology involved.
He says,
he says since he can occasionally find some group that hasn't been to war for 20
years or something like that,
then it can't be biology.
And the view of biology that many social sciences have is sort of that
everything is,
if it's biology to knee,
knee,
jerk reflex,
know if you're not,
if your nervous system is not impaired,
every time I hit your knee with a hammer,
your knee will kick out and there's no volition.
And they say,
so if we ever seen a human not doing some behavior,
that behavior cannot be instinctual.
Of course that was disproven,
uh,
in around 1910 by Pavlov,
you all know about Pavlov.
So he takes an instinct as basic as eating,
and a dog sees a piece of meat start salivating and then very rapidly he rings a
bell a minute before,
uh,
the dog sees the meat and the dog starts salivating to the bell.
So since 1910,
at least,
we've known that even the most basic behavior,
uh,
can,
can be,
uh,
can be controlled by something with a small,
smaller brain as a dog,
even though one would never say the dog does not have an eating instinct,
does not have a salivating instinct too.
Of course they do.
And yet dogs can control it.
I tell a story about my dog,
so a smallish whites,
Samoan,
and I'm at work all day.
I work long hours.
And so she's at home all day and you know,
by the time I come home,
she's a little frustrated,
you know,
she's been cooped up and I'm a little frustrated.
So you know what happens?
I get down on my hands and knees and I growl at her.
She immediately picks up the queue.
Okay.
Snarling back at me
and I,
I swatter one,
you know,
genital spot,
but she gets,
she snipped back at my hand and we go at it.
We have a great time.
Unfortunately my dog has died,
but we have it.
We had a great time.
Uh,
and in the course of these,
you know,
she's snapping and she's aroused.
Oh,
her hair is standing on an,
her tail is straight up.
Her fangs are,
are showed and she's,
she's snapping away at me and I get maybe
shift.
We do 20 minutes or so,
maybe at least 50 to a hundred.
You know,
bites.
Where she actually,
she went,
I know I,
when I smack her,
she wins.
And,
but what's,
so that means over the years I've had many tens of thousands of times where
she's,
you know,
grab me and all that.
And guess what?
Not once in all those many thousands of bites,
has she ever pierce my skin?
All right,
this is a peaceful house door.
She doesn't know anything about killing.
No,
not true.
In the morning I take her out and running in the woods.
I know that she takes me to her,
I take her and if she sees a bird or a squirrel,
she's off and she comes back with a dead dead bird in her mouth,
clearly killed.
She clearly been through their skin,
you know,
very,
very proud walking there with a dad's girl.
So here's an animal and I love her dearly,
but her brain was,
is not very big and she can get into the depths of really instinctual responses.
And yet her brain is clever enough to be able to control it and not end to kill
the squirrel,
but not to kill me or not to even break through my skin.
So I think the idea is a lot of people think when you describe a biological
basis for behavior,
that it's inevitable.
Human species are lost.
We're never going to change.
But that's,
that's nonsense.
Humans are like,
chimpanzees are quite intelligent and we are caving.
We haven't in,
I believe that we have instincts for sure.
You'll see it come out in the most horrible ways and some of the good ways,
uh,
but it's not that difficult to control.
My dog can do it.
You guys can do
the other issue,
which these are good topics for discussion in the sections is some people also
say when I describe like ducks rape or orangutans rape that of by describing it
and saying that animals do it,
I'm justifying it,
you know,
and there's this whole thing now that what's natural is good and what animals do
is natural and therefore it's good.
And this slops over into foods and everything.
But uh,
this whole idea of natural law,
uh,
that,
that you can tell from nature what is good and what is bad is,
is,
is not to be taken seriously.
Okay.
That finishes that topic and I think you've had enough violence.
I want to skip a switch to the opposite side.
Now demography is of course,
births and deaths,
that those are the two main things in demography.
And we've been talking about one of the main causes of human death on one side.
And we find that there is a clear continuity between chimpanzees and humans.
Now let's talk about the other side births.
And they're surprisingly,
humans are drastically different from chimpanzees.
And so how do we know this?
Well,
chimpanzees who are never very successful demographically,
uh,
at their peak,
there may have been 2 million chimpanzees,
uh,
a very small Chinese cities,
2 million individuals.
Um,
and,
uh,
because of the rise of humans,
they're taking over their territory.
They,
the guests is,
they'd been reduced to about a hundred thousand,
uh,
5% of their early of their peak population.
They're restricted to central Africa.
They have never spread,
uh,
beyond central Africa.
Humans,
on the other hand is,
you know,
a number in the billions.
We spread to the farthest corners of the earth from the ice cap around the North
Pole to the hottest desert and jungle.
Um,
there are 10,000,
tens of thousands of times as many people,
humans as there are chimpanzees,
and humans have become absolutely dominant,
basically everywhere on earth.
So from a demographic point of view,
maybe the first question we should ask,
why are there so many humans?
And so few chips.
What is the secret of our demographic,
uh,
success?
Let me give you a clue about the timescale.
We separated,
uh,
from chimps about 6 million years ago,
and I've shown you,
oh,
this is another version of the deaths.
Uh,
don't worry about it.
remember this,
this,
uh,
the family tree here and here is the split point where humans branched off from
chimps and Bonobos and it's ballpark 6 million years ago,
uh,
that we split off the population size.
What is believed that the population size,
uh,
of the,
all of the,
the,
the group that became these three species was only about 50,000 individuals at
the split point that comes from the genetics,
the variation in genetics.
And,
uh,
this a small group branched off and started behaving,
evolving quite differently.
Uh,
so what happens when you have a small group to begin with,
a 50,000 breeding individuals and then a small groove breaks off and they may
further subdivided into small groups that may not come much in contact with each
other.
You have inbreeding,
inbreeding,
uh,
caused a lot of genetic problem to also allows evolution to go very rapidly for
mutation that is beneficial,
appears it can spread to a small population very rapidly where it's extremely
difficult for to spread into a large population.
So the tininess of,
of the number of our human ancestors allowed a rather rapid evolution away from
the other groups who are also evolving of course,
cause they're also in small groups.
And um,
that at,
at this split you start going down this pathway and it's shown here as a single
line,
but it's all of,
you know,
from the newspaper,
there are many,
many species splitting off at different times with different characteristics all
in the,
the humanoid,
the hominid line and,
but by chance all of those other species went extinct except one.
And that's another characters.
If you're a small group then it's very easy to go extinct.
And for all of the other,
we know 120 30 other hominid species and all went extinct except one the genus
Homo,
which is the group of species in which we set the region is about two and a half
million years ago.
And they start calling skeletons homo sapiens about a half a million years ago.
But even though they're homosapiens,
their brains are,
are at that time significantly smaller than ours are now in an anatomically
modern humans date,
only from about a hundred to 150,000 years ago.
And all during this period,
the number of humans was clearly very small.
And so it's very humbling to realize that with a small group that's evolving
rapidly,
which means it's not yet mastered its environment because you don't want to,
your,
uh,
have optimized your relationship to environment,
evolution slows down.
But if we are evolving rapidly,
that means we haven't yet mastered it.
So a small group,
a struggling in its environment,
very likely to go extinct.
Most of our sibling species went extinct.
And I think with a very small roll of the dice differently,
the line towards humans could easily have gone extinct.
It seems.
Uh,
and had about a hundred thousand years ago,
there was a bottleneck in the growth of human species and the humans living at
that time,
a small group where the ancestors to all current,
uh,
human beings,
there was a small population of about two to 10,000.
They believe that was the total human population from two to 10,000 of humans
living in Africa and interbreeding there may have been other human population
somewhere else that,
that that disappeared.
We don't know.
And the numbers two to 10,000,
some research puts them a few times higher.
We don't really know.
Uh,
but again,
very small number.
We know from that period that there was substance,
no substantial population growth.
So that means the average number of surviving children was,
was two or maybe eensy weensy a bit higher than two.
So that meant when you have on average two children per couple,
that means that most lineages have died out.
That most individuals who are living at that time of this small number now leave
no descendants at all.
And if you trace back,
the genetics suggests that all current humans,
all races over the world are the descendants of a single human female that every
other line from the time when she was alive has died out.
And similarly for males,
we are the,
all the descendants of a single human male,
all other lines have died out.
And those two didn't have to live at the same time.
In fact,
almost certainly did not live at the same time.
It's just the randomness of lines dying out.
And the genetics tells us that we know the rate at which DNA chain mutates and
diverges.
And so we,
and we know the range of variation in current humans.
So we just sort of narrowed that back and it goes back to this,
what did I say a hundred thousand years ago?
So that's the,
the,
the genetic eve and the genetic Adam that the newspapers just,
just love this story.
But it's,
you know,
it's just a common result of a slowly at population that doesn't have a lot of
surviving children lines are going to die out.
You can read that the royal houses of Europe is where you're all exposed to it.
Look how few generations,
the royal houses last before they don't have any heirs and that's in modern or
these are the richest people at their time and have all the food and protection,
everything that they want and they can't stay going for more than a few
generations.
And so in primitive times,
the rate of extinction of,
of lines was,
was great.
So about 50,000 years ago,
so we were to spend a few million years in Africa.
Then about 50,000 years ago,
a group of humans migrated out of Africa.
And again,
the numbers and the time,
some people say it was as late as 25,000 years ago,
that they migrate it out.
But then amazing things happen once they burst out on the rest of the world.
They spread everywhere.
Humans are found everywhere on the Eurasian continent.
And that's from Siberia to Spain.
Um,
uh,
by about 20,000 years ago.
And then from Siberia,
they crossed the Bering strait,
which was a land bridge at that time,
and expanded it into the Americas and reach the very tip of South America by
10,000 years ago.
So in 40,000 years,
uh,
which is a blink of an eye in evolutionary terms,
humans spread everywhere on earth,
an incredible population explosion.
This is the first and greatest explosion of population explosions of humans.
And you should note that something was making us superior at that time and
clearly has nothing to do with modern technology.
This,
all of this fantastic expansion even predates the invention of agriculture and
most of what we consider a civilization,
uh,
starts with,
with agriculture.
So what does the main difference set of law has allowed this story that humans
have done this and chimps have,
have done this?
And will you ask,
what is the reproductive rate of chimpanzees?
Well,
I've told you is that a chimp mother has one young every five to eight years.
So at that rate,
it's going to be very hard to increase at any,
any great speed.
But human females have babies much more frequently.
Uh,
it's quite possible to have a baby every year or every year and a half or two
years.
And this is common.
My,
my brother was born 20 months apart from me.
How many of you have siblings less than two years apart?
Yeah,
most of you.
So humans are quite capable of doing something that chimps just cannot do.
Uh,
they have a rate of reproduction about four or five times slower than we do the
mothers.
The chimp mothers cannot take care of more than one young at a time.
They will have a young that's clinging to them and then perhaps an adolescent,
a son or daughter with them,
but they'll never,
you're never see two infants at a time.
Whereas humans,
it can easily take care of two infants at a time.
What
twins in chimps?
I have never heard or read anything about chimps occurring in twins occurring in
chimps.
And I don't know whether
they ever do.
It may be just that we don't have a enough observation that may be occasionally
Chin twins do happen,
but it's not,
not been reported that I've seen anybody take it.
Oh,
not about two months.
I was just going to ask you if that's regulated completely.
Like,
like you would say that on lactation stops.
Yes.
Maybe for five years.
Uh,
they're nursing them for a long time.
I don't recall what the,
what the number is,
but there's many behavioral mechanisms.
So in nursing,
the actual physical stimulation of the nipple releases hormones,
oxytocin,
which prevents ovulation again.
And that can be prolonged for quite a period of time,
but it's not absolute.
So there are other behavioral mechanisms,
other internal hormonal mechanisms which ensure this and chimpanzees,
we very hard to capture a chimp and do the physiology and experiment.
So we basically probably don't know most of the answer to the,
to that question.
Okay.
So the,
a major difference in the,
in between humans and chimps is a tremendous increase in human fecundity.
Now,
in,
in demography,
we use word fecundity means,
uh,
the ability to have children.
Fertility means the number of children who actually have in common.
That's comes from French usage.
The French use the word sort of opposite to the way we do.
And demography was born in France.
So when I say fertility,
I don't mean the ability to have children,
that's for [inaudible],
but I mean the number children that any given set of women actually have.
So we have to ask ourselves what evolutionary factors allowed this change and
for quantity.
And so what limited a chimp population and expand what limited chimp for
Kennedy.
Well,
in primate evolution,
the main factor is the time that brain development takes a body that's capable
of walking and chewing and so forth can develop rather rapidly in all kinds of
animals develop on very short timescale on her immediately capable of doing
those things.
But if you're going to have a species with a big brain,
that's a slow process.
And so in,
in all the,
all the higher brain,
the bigger brain primates,
the slow thing is his brain development.
And in order to not have to carry this baby,
like for till the brain is mature,
it at like age 13 or something,
they say we don't really progress beyond adolescence.
Uh,
so in humans and,
and great apes,
the baby is born with physically somewhat mature,
but the brain is still growing enormously.
So really there's postnatal fetal development of the brain.
So even at the nine months of pregnancy,
we're not at the end of the period of,
of brain told the brain is nowhere near its final size or complexity.
Um,
so,
uh,
that limits the,
the rate at which one can have childbirth.
And because of the,
the infant is born in chimps and humans is born,
uh,
incapable of taking care of itself.
The mother has to stay with the child and,
and,
and take care of it.
And in chimps,
the mother stays exclusively with her infant for several years.
Um,
and the chimps get very little,
as I mentioned,
to very little in the way of resources from the males.
They mostly you watch and they do,
they don't come in contact with males all that much.
They,
they and their young forage by themselves and etc. Etc.
And the males are just patrolling.
They see them every so often in the males protect,
uh,
the boundaries.
But in terms of taking care of the young,
the males basically have no role whatsoever as a result of this need to have
intense care of the young and no help from anyone.
Sometimes other females will help but basically no help at all.
The period in which the mother has to devote herself exclusively to that one
young is quite prolonged.
Now in humans,
males do play some more intimate part in child rearing,
not anywhere near as much as a,
as a female,
but they do bring resources in general.
In most human societies over time,
males are responsible for bringing some resources to the female on a rather
continuing basis.
And we don't really know how this evolved because these things,
you can't really tell these things from fossils.
Um,
but what we know is that Africa,
the chimps started in the jungle and then Africa started drawing out.
And so some subset of the chimps maybe pushed out by stronger individuals are
clever individuals were pushed into this drawing out more grasslands where there
was a west cover and less fruiting trees.
Dry Land doesn't produce the big fruiting trees that chimps depend on.
So as the different twin chimps and Bonobos,
when there's a lesser food density,
the population has to spread out that if an individual is going to find any
food,
they're not going to find enough for a large group.
So individual females would have to go forward,
uh,
quite separately.
And you can speculate further that as the female spread out,
the dominant males could no longer keep watch over and control over these
females.
They were just too far a spread geographically
and so wildly in chimps.
A while a male and a female may go off for a short time,
uh,
period,
in,
in what's called the concert ship.
And there may be meetings at that time.
There's no lasting,
no,
no continuing a relationship between any particular male and a female.
Uh,
the chimpanzees,
as I mentioned,
her mail bonded and they spend more time with each other.
Male to male than the males do.
Uh,
with the females in humans,
of course,
we still have a lot of what they call male,
male bonding,
military units,
sports teams,
whole male clubs,
football,
wedding parties,
or watching football,
watching parties,
et cetera.
But we've evolved in the direction of much more male female interaction and
context.
Female sexuality,
uh,
changed a while.
Chimpanzees always made from behind humans.
Humans engage in frontal copulation.
And since the face is how humans,
and also chimpanzees,
uh,
detect each other,
they know individuals largely by their facial structure and they detect
emotions.
It's very important part of mutation,
detect the emotions and respond to each other's by,
by facial cues.
So this face to face interaction,
especially in the intense intensity of a sexual encounter,
it considered a large part of the evolution of male,
female bonding.
And sorry,
I forgot to show you last time,
but this an excuse to show you this time here is,
uh,
button Bonobo,
engaging in,
in fund to funds sex,
male and female here.
And she's grinning.
She's clearly,
uh,
being pretty happy about this.
And I also said I would show you this is two females,
uh,
doing the same thing.
If you didn't,
if I didn't tell you it was,
this was two females,
you wouldn't know the difference unless you're watching.
You can see that they both have their,
their swellings on.
That's how you tell that,
that they're two females.
I mean,
the guys take the picture obviously a lot more,
but you can tell it.
So this is what I described that the locals called it Hoka Hoka.
And
so this whole evolution of sexuality,
um,
in,
uh,
the human line,
the cliteracy has moved forward,
uh,
for fee,
which in face to face copulation probably makes it a more female pleasure
during,
uh,
the act of copulation and therefore again,
reinforces this bonding.
So another big difference is this is not an extreme case of,
of,
uh,
of the rump.
Um,
that's another,
another time,
um,
that humans do not advertise their estrus.
Not only do we not remember the,
the,
the chimps advertise their estrous in order to get the males together and have
the males compete for them.
Humans keep it secret.
Not only don't the males know when a,
when a female is in estrus a,
but the female herself does not know when she's in estrus.
And for a very long time it was believed that females are fertile during their
periods.
And it was only in the 1930s that it was found out by a Japanese group that
females are fertile in the mid period between their periods.
And even further,
it was believed in the 1930s that females are fertile a few days before and a
few days after the middle of,
of,
uh,
oscillation in the middle of the period.
And in fact,
we now know just from about 10 years ago,
that the actual fertile period always is only precedes of ovulation.
That intercourse must take place before ovulation.
So not only do we do human female is not advertised to the females they don't
know.
And scientists with all our invasion of just now finally figured out,
we think,
uh,
when a human female is fertile.
So this is a big,
big,
big change.
It's such a big part,
the advertising such a big part of a primate sexuality,
uh,
why as it disappeared in humans.
Um,
so,
uh,
it may be sort of the reverse that if females are out there alone and there's
carnivores,
you read about this from the Rj that are,
you know,
lions and tigers out there ready to eat them and they need protection of various
sorts and maybe help in finding food.
So it's important to have a male hanging around and a male evolutionary purpose.
He wants to inseminate the female.
So if he knows when a female is having estrus,
he has to be there then to inseminate her.
But if he knows when she is an actress,
he also knows when she is not in estrus and when she's not an estrus,
he may have no evolutionary pushed to stay there,
but go out and try to find some other female.
So the purpose of not showing your estrus may be to keep the mail uncertain of
when you're fertile and therefore he has to attend to the female all the time.
And once he's there,
he might as well help her because that will ensure that whatever inference come
along are,
are in good shape.
So,
uh,
if that's correct,
and certainly males and females started spending more time together and they're
more disperse,
that reduces a male male competition.
Remembering the male male competition is the result of a group in which a lot of
males stay together.
When you're more dispersed,
male male competition has to be reduced.
And so it looks like the in,
in the evolution to humans,
that's what switching is from the advertising,
which allows the males to compete in the female,
gets the mail with the best jeans.
She's switching to wanting resources from the mail.
She's no longer interested so much in male competition,
but in whatever resources the male can bring to her by having a male around,
uh,
continually,
this story is rather complicated and very controversial.
This is a very nice reading,
uh,
in your packet might be interesting too.
Oh boy.
To consider that.
Uh,
how does the male respond to this change in strategy?
Um,
if Mona,
if the road to monogamy starts going down,
then paternity becomes more certain that in a,
in the chimps where of females copulating with everyone.
Uh,
there's no reason to be certain of paternity,
uh,
at all.
But once it becomes clear that yes,
this child is,
is almost certainly mine,
then it becomes evolutionary advantageous for the mail to start putting
resources into this mother and child because that ensures their survival and
things start developing in a different direction.
We're stabled pairing becomes evolutionarily advantage.
The male putting resources into the,
into the payer is for evolutionary advantage.
So it's,
it seems pretty clear that an increase in the mail contribution to child rearing
is one of the major reasons for the increased fertility of humans.
Why humans are able to out reproduce.
Chimpanzees,
of course is as you all are aware of,
monogamy has not by any means,
uh,
taken human societies totally over and some societies,
overtly a sanction polygamy.
But even in our culture,
which Europe and North America genetic testing shows that 10 to 15% of humans do
not have the father that they're supposed to have.
That father is usually defined as the resident mail is not farther.
And that's,
uh,
quite a large percentage.
American women,
uh,
report six different sexual partners lifetime,
and males report 16 female partners lifetime.
Now one thing we know quantum,
if you're at all mathematical that the,
since two,
it takes two to tango,
the average has to be the same.
So he can't be both six and 16.
And uh,
who knows?
Possibly somewhere in between is correct,
but probably higher because these things tend to be under reported.
No one wants to really say how well females certainly don't want to say,
how come the skew us?
They are.
You're usually,
and also there's old data.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
from 2001,
and with the change of sexual mores in the Western countries,
I'm sure the numbers are exponentially increasing.
Uh,
so what's another thing about this thing with respect to human evolution is that
when you're a chimpanzee,
the mail,
the main form of competition is male,
male fighting,
male male status,
jocking,
which takes certain amount of intelligence to arrange coalitions and so forth.
But basically,
evolution is pushing you to be a big and violent.
Now the individual dispersed the male stays with the female and male starts
springing resource violence is decreased.
The importance of that in the mail evolution decreases.
And the importance of being able to provide resources becomes evolutionary
important.
So the kind of intelligence required to find food in a scarce environment,
to find shelter,
to protect from animals and so forth becomes important.
So a fair reason for the increase in human,
uh,
mental capacity might also be this shift from a dependence on violence for
competition to,
uh,
a dependence on resource acquisition of resources for competition and for
evolution.
So,
okay.
Um,
I'd run out of time and so we will continue,
uh,
with humans and how they are different from chimps.
Next time.